Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Metrolinks and Crosslinks are reminding everyone to be careful, as Eglinton Crosstown LRT train testing is in progress. Please be alert, as trains can pass at any time on the tracks. Remember to follow all traffic signals, be careful along our tracks, and only make left turns where it's safe to do so. Be alert, be aware, and stay safe. Hello, Tom Holland here. This is just to warn you that this episode contains sexually sensitive content.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。Metrolinks 和 Crosslinks 提醒大家注意安全，埃格林顿跨城轻轨（Eglinton Crosstown LRT）列车测试正在进行中。请保持警惕，因为列车随时可能经过轨道。请务必遵守所有交通信号，在轨道沿线保持谨慎，并仅在安全的情况下进行左转。保持警觉，注意周围环境，确保安全。你好，我是汤姆·霍兰德。这只是为了提醒你，本集包含性敏感内容。
So please do be warned. But don't necessarily be put off listening to it for that reason. The subject of conversation, of curiosity, of enthusiasm almost, one might say, of the moment, is not Spain or Portugal, warriors or patriots, but Lord Byron. His poem is on every table, and himself courted, visited, flattered and praised wherever he appears. He has a pale, sickly, but handsome countenance. A bad figure, animated but amusing conversation, and in short, he is really the only topic almost of every conversation. The men jealous of him, the women of each other.
所以请务必注意。但不必因此而放弃收听。此刻人们谈论、好奇、甚至可以说是热衷的话题，既不是西班牙或葡萄牙，也不是战士或爱国者，而是拜伦勋爵。他的诗作摆在每张桌子上，他本人无论出现在哪里，都受到追捧、拜访、奉承和赞美。他面色苍白、病态，但容貌英俊。身材不佳，谈吐生动而有趣，简而言之，他几乎是所有谈话中唯一的主题。男人们嫉妒他，女人们则互相嫉妒。
Sir Tom Holland, that was the Duchess of Devonshire, and she was writing in the spring of 1812 to her son. So her son at the time was Britain's ambassador to the United States. He'd soon be coming home after the outbreak of war between Britain and the US. So we're in the middle of the Napoleonic Wars. And last week, you took us brilliantly through the story of Lord Byron, his very, very turbulent childhood, his travels in the Balkans and the Mediterranean. And he has returned home, he's published Childe Harold's Pilgrimage, and it has become this unbelievable overnight hit,
汤姆·霍兰德爵士，那是德文郡公爵夫人，她是在1812年春天写信给她的儿子。当时她的儿子是英国驻美国大使。在英美战争爆发后，他很快就要回国了。所以我们正处于拿破仑战争期间。上周，你精彩地讲述了拜伦勋爵的故事，他非常、非常动荡的童年，以及他在巴尔干半岛和地中海的旅行。他已经回国，出版了《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》，并且一夜之间取得了令人难以置信的成功，
arguably the first such hit in literary history. Yeah, I think so. And he's become this new phenomenon, a celebrity. So sales of this poem are going through the roof, just like with the Beatles, all the producers who turned the Beatles down are kicking themselves. So publishers are kicking themselves as they watch John Murray, the guy who had taken a punt on Childe Harold, moving flush with the proceeds into splendid new quarters on Albemarle Street off Piccadilly, where John Murray is still going. It's still a going concern. They still have those rooms. And Byron, I think, is a celebrity in the way that we would recognise a celebrity, not least because he's absolutely brilliant at manipulating and controlling his image.
可以说是文学史上第一次出现这样的热销。是的，我想是这样。他已经成为了这种新的现象，一位名人。所以这首诗的销量直线上升，就像披头士乐队一样，所有拒绝过披头士的制作人都后悔莫及。出版商们也在后悔，他们看着约翰·默里（John Murray）——那个敢于冒险出版《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》的人——带着收益搬进了皮卡迪利大街旁阿尔伯马尔街（Albemarle Street）上豪华的新办公地点，约翰·默里至今仍在那里经营。它仍然是一家持续经营的企业。他们仍然保留着那些房间。而且我认为，拜伦是一位我们所认知的意义上的名人，尤其是因为他非常擅长操纵和控制自己的形象。
So in that bit, you read the description of him being pale sickly but handsome i mean that's very much the vibe that he's going for so he he he avoids appearing in the morning because he feels that that doesn't show him off to best light so it's kind of quite a vampiric sense of himself as a creature of the night and he is obsessively concerned with his dress so kind of very distinctive look you know the open shirt the black cloak you know he's spending a lot of money on his tailoring, which I think is very commendable. Also great enthusiasts for white quilted waistcoats and white trousers of the finest cotton or silk. And he'll buy a dozen, two dozen of these at a go. And just like a celebrity today, you know, controlling how they look, their appearance, photographs and things. I mean, Byron is doing this with paintings, with portrayals of him, plates of him will appear in his volumes of poetry. You know, he's studying it very,
所以在刚才那段里，你读到了对他的描述，说他面色苍白、病态但英俊，我的意思是，这非常符合他所追求的氛围。所以他避免在早上露面，因为他觉得那样不能展现他最好的一面，所以他有一种相当吸血鬼式的自我感觉，把自己看作是黑夜的生物。他非常痴迷于自己的着装，所以有一种非常独特的造型，你知道，敞开的衬衫、黑色斗篷，他在裁缝上花了很多钱，我认为这非常值得称赞。他还非常热衷于白色绗缝背心和用最精细的棉布或丝绸制成的白色长裤。他一次会买一打、两打。就像今天的名人一样，你知道，控制他们的外表、形象、照片等等。我的意思是，拜伦正在通过绘画、对他的描绘来做到这一点，他的诗集里会出现他的版画。你知道，他研究得非常，
very closely. He is again, like a celebrity, obsessive about his weight. We talked in the previous episode how basically, I mean, he's bulimic and he's got this new thing where he started to chew gum as an appetite repressant. Oh my word. So he's probably the first celebrity to have chewing gum. First gum chewing celebrity. You describe him as a celebrity. Now you're probably not aware of this guy, but there's a guy who's written a history of celebrity. Oh, Greg Jenner. Called Greg Jenner. Have you ever heard of him, Tom? I believe he runs podcasts, doesn't he? So he doesn't quite agree that Byron is the first celebrity.
非常仔细。他再次像个名人一样，对自己的体重非常痴迷。我们在上一集谈到他基本上患有暴食症，而且他有一种新习惯，开始嚼口香糖作为食欲抑制剂。天哪。所以他可能是第一个拥有口香糖的名人。第一个嚼口香糖的名人。你把他描述为名人。现在你可能不知道这个人，但有一个人写过一本关于名人的历史。哦，格雷格·詹纳（Greg Jenner）。叫格雷格·詹纳。你听说过他吗，汤姆？我相信他经营播客，不是吗？所以他不太同意拜伦是第一个名人。
He actually says that Dr. Sir Cheverell from the early 18th century, the disputatious Anglican clergyman, is the first celebrity. Capple Loft is a big fan of his, isn't he? Our intemperate listener. Yes, our intemperate listener. So celebrity is something that is driven by print culture, obviously. Yeah, and I think that's the key thing, but also by commercial culture. If you remember, we did the episode on fashion in Jane Austen. Yeah. And it's in exactly this period that fashion starts changing every year
他实际上说，18世纪初的萨切弗雷尔博士（Dr. Sacheverell），那位好争论的圣公会牧师，才是第一个名人。卡普尔·洛夫特（Capple Loft）是他的忠实粉丝，不是吗？我们那位放纵的听众。是的，我们那位放纵的听众。所以名人是由印刷文化驱动的，显然。是的，我认为这是关键，但也是由商业文化驱动的。如果你还记得，我们做过关于简·奥斯汀时代时尚的那一集。是的。正是在这个时期，时尚开始每年都在变化，
because there are enough people with money to do that. Right. And I think that that is the key. And so Byron is fashionable in that sense. So this is my question, because you compared a couple of times the emergence of Byron with the emergence of the Beatles, who of course also celebrities of a new kind when they break through in between 1962 and 1964. But with the Beatles, you could say the market, the industry already exists. Had the Beatles not existed, someone would have needed to invent them. Is that also the case with Lord Byron. Yeah, I think so. And I think you can be very materialist about it, that it's about the infrastructure of publishing that enables it to happen. It's not like the Beatles in The Beatles are a mass phenomenon. This is obviously restricted to people who can afford books. And it's particularly centred, I think, of course, on the aristocracy. But because there are the equivalent of, I guess, of Vogue magazines that are reporting
因为有足够多有钱的人来做这件事。对。我认为这就是关键。所以拜伦在那个意义上是时尚的。所以这是我的问题，因为你几次将拜伦的出现与披头士的出现进行了比较，他们当然也是在1962年到1964年间走红时的一种新型名人。但对于披头士来说，你可以说市场和行业已经存在了。如果披头士不存在，也会有人需要发明他们。拜伦勋爵也是这样吗？是的，我想是这样。而且我认为你可以对此非常唯物主义，即这与使之成为可能的出版基础设施有关。这不像披头士，披头士是一种大众现象。这显然仅限于买得起书的人。而且我认为，它当然特别集中在贵族阶层。但因为有相当于，我想，Vogue杂志那样的刊物在报道
the doings of the aristocracy, Byron's fame ripples outwards from that. And as with celebrities today, you get a fan culture. Yeah. And as with Beatlemania, it is hugely driven by women. So you get obsessive Byron fans. They are writing him letters detailing all their fantasies about him. They're writing, asking him for locks of hair. They are stalking him. And Byron is incredibly disconcerted by this because I don't think anyone has ever experienced anything quite like this.
贵族们的所作所为，拜伦的名声便由此向外扩散。而且和今天的名人一样，你会有粉丝文化。是的。而且和披头士狂热一样，它在很大程度上是由女性推动的。所以你会有痴迷的拜伦粉丝。她们给他写信，详细描述她们对他所有的幻想。她们写信要求他提供一缕头发。她们跟踪他。而拜伦对此感到非常不安，因为我不认为有人曾经经历过这样的事情。
So he pretends to be dismissive of it, but secretly, I mean, we know about these fan letters because he keeps them. He keeps them kind of locked away. And the other thing, of course, that is also familiar from the recent history of celebrity, and I guess maybe even more in Hollywood, perhaps, than anywhere else, is that Byron has very deep gay fantasies, desires. And this has to be repressed because his female fan base will not appreciate it so again there is that sense of celebrity being accompanied by a kind of an erotic self-repression which is also a part of certainly of 20th century celebrity the tremendous pressure of being the subject of the
所以他假装对此不屑一顾，但私下里，我的意思是，我们知道这些粉丝信，因为他保留了它们。他把它们锁起来了。当然，还有另一件事，这在最近的名人历史中也很熟悉，我想也许在好莱坞比在其他任何地方都更甚，那就是拜伦有非常深层的同性幻想和欲望。这必须被压抑，因为他的女性粉丝群不会欣赏它，所以再次出现了那种名人伴随着一种色情自我压抑的感觉，这也是20世纪名人的一部分，成为粉丝文化对象的巨大压力，
fan culture i mean the the object of every gaze i guess which is something a modern celebrity would be completely familiar with byron has this even though people, you said that it's an aristocratic thing, and obviously that makes sense because most people aren't, but I mean, ultimately you said 10,000 copies of the poetry book. That's tiny in a country of millions. But is Byron conscious when he leaves London that people know who he is, that he's a name to be conjured with? Is his name spreading, would you say? Yes, I think so. Because he's not going to remote villages to hang out, but he is going to Bath, he's going to Brighton, he's going to places where the fashionable hang out and where the fashionable will be reported on. And he is the person who's reported on. And I think that you
我的意思是，成为每一道目光的焦点，我想这是现代名人会非常熟悉的事情。拜伦即使在人们——你说这是一种贵族现象，显然这说得通，因为大多数人不是贵族，但我的意思是，最终你说诗集卖了1万册。在数百万人口的国家里，这微不足道。但拜伦在离开伦敦时是否意识到人们知道他是谁，他是一个响当当的名字？你会说他的名声在传播吗？是的，我想是这样。因为他不是去偏远村庄闲逛，而是去巴斯，去布莱顿，去那些时尚人士聚集的地方，以及那些会被报道的地方。而他就是那个被报道的人。而且我认为你
get a measure perhaps of his fame by the way in which elements of the Byronic, for instance, start to appear in Jane Austen's novels. So Pride and Prejudice will come out the year after Byron turns famous. And I think there are elements of Byron in Mr. Darcy, and he is name-checked in Persuasion, Jane Austen's last novel. And I think the sense of what it is to be an attractive, charismatic, aristocratic figure. Byron is having a huge influence on this. And as you say, it generates huge emotional pressure on him. And I think that that explains why from the beginning, his celebrity is shadowed by scandal. And there are three relationships in particular that, I mean, it's kind of like Pride and Pre on hard drugs i mean it is an amazing extraordinary
也许可以通过拜伦式的元素开始出现在简·奥斯汀的小说中来衡量他的名声。所以《傲慢与偏见》是在拜伦成名后一年出版的。我认为达西先生身上有拜伦的影子，而且他在简·奥斯汀的最后一部小说《劝导》中被点名了。我认为关于成为一个有吸引力、有魅力、贵族式人物的感觉。拜伦对此产生了巨大的影响。正如你所说，这给他带来了巨大的情感压力。而且我认为这解释了为什么从一开始，他的名声就被丑闻所笼罩。特别是有三段关系，我的意思是，这有点像《傲慢与偏见》吸了毒，我的意思是，这是一个令人惊叹的、非凡的、
authentically scandalous story yeah and that's basically the subject of today's episode yes so if you like bad behavior and particularly bad behavior sexual conduct this is the episode for you and if you don't other episodes are available yeah they're there absolutely are. So the first of these three affairs, three relationships, it involves a woman who Fiona McCarthy in her brilliant biography of Byron describes as the fan to end all fans. And this is Lady Caroline Lamb, who is the wife of William Lamb, who on the death of his father in 1828 will become Lord Melbourne. Queen Victoria's first prime minister. So Rufus Sewell.
真实且丑闻不断的故事。是的，这基本上就是今天这一集的主题。是的，所以如果你喜欢糟糕的行为，特别是糟糕的性行为，这一集就是为你准备的。如果你不喜欢，还有其他剧集可供选择。是的，绝对有。所以这三段恋情中的第一段，涉及一位女性，菲奥娜·麦卡锡（Fiona McCarthy）在她精彩的拜伦传记中将其描述为“终极粉丝”。这就是卡罗琳·兰姆夫人（Lady Caroline Lamb），她是威廉·兰姆（William Lamb）的妻子，威廉·兰姆在1828年他父亲去世后将成为墨尔本勋爵。维多利亚女王的第一任首相。所以是鲁弗斯·塞维尔（Rufus Sewell）。
Yeah, Rufus Sewell, if you've seen the TV series about Queen Victoria. So he is actually quite a distant husband, quite an austere husband. The marriage isn't entirely happy. Caroline has two miscarriages and then she has a son who survives. But she's not really suited to a kind of slightly chill, ironic figure like her husband, because she is very restless, wild, ferocious. And her mother-in-law, Lady Melbourne, who doesn't like her at all, calls her the little beast. And it's not just in her manners that she's eccentric, but in her appearance. Is this Fiona McCarthy, Tom? Very amusing.
是的，鲁弗斯·塞维尔，如果你看过关于维多利亚女王的电视剧的话。所以他实际上是一个相当疏远的丈夫，相当严厉的丈夫。这段婚姻并不完全幸福。卡罗琳流产了两次，然后生下了一个幸存的儿子。但她并不适合像她丈夫那样稍微冷淡、讽刺的人物，因为她非常不安分、狂野、凶猛。她的婆婆墨尔本夫人（Lady Melbourne）一点也不喜欢她，称她为“小野兽”。她不仅在举止上古怪，在外表上也如此。这是菲奥娜·麦卡锡写的吗，汤姆？非常有趣。
So this is Benita Eisler who's also written a great biography. So description of Lady Caroline Lamb. She was small, unfashionably slender and flat chested in an age that admired opulent female attributes, splendid snowy breasts, buttocks and bellies. Daringly she had cut her hair and her short flaxen
这是贝妮塔·艾斯勒（Benita Eisler）写的，她也写过一本很棒的传记。所以这是对卡罗琳·兰姆夫人的描述。她身材娇小，瘦得不合时宜，胸部平坦，而在那个崇尚丰满女性特征、拥有华丽雪白乳房、臀部和腹部的时代。她大胆地剪短了头发，她那短促的亚麻色
curls framed a thin face that large dark eyes caused to seem even thinner. So in other words, she looks like a boy. And not only that, Dominic, but she actually enjoys dressing up as a page boy. So she's kind of gamine, I guess. Yes. We know that Byron has a thing for page boys. Yeah.
卷发衬托着一张瘦削的脸，那双又大又黑的眼睛使脸显得更瘦了。换句话说，她看起来像个男孩。不仅如此，多米尼克，她实际上喜欢打扮成侍童。所以我想她有点像个假小子。是的。我们知道拜伦对侍童情有独钟。是的。
So all the ingredients are there. And Caroline is very romantic. And so she, of course, reads Childe Harold's Pilgrimage. She's swept away by it. She writes him a fan letter. But then when they meet at a ball, she cuts him dead. You know, their eyes meet and she just moves away, which, of course, is calculated to pique his interest.
所以所有的要素都在那里。而且卡罗琳非常浪漫。所以她当然读了《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》。她被它深深吸引。她给他写了一封粉丝信。但当他们在舞会上见面时，她对他视而不见。你知道，他们的目光相遇，她却走开了，这当然是为了激起他的兴趣。
Oh, my God. Yeah. Textbook. Yeah. And then Byron is at Holland House. So this wig salon. Tremendously named centre of wig salons. Yes. And the Melron is at Holland House. So this wig salons. Tremendously named center of wig salons. Yes. And the Melbournes also are wigs. So they're very kind of intimate, close.
天哪。是的。教科书级别的。是的。然后拜伦在荷兰庄园（Holland House）。所以这个沙龙。非常著名的沙龙中心。是的。墨尔本一家也在荷兰庄园。所以这个沙龙。非常著名的沙龙中心。是的。墨尔本一家也是沙龙常客。所以他们非常亲密。
And so Byron is there. Caroline knows he's there. The Melbournes have a house, Dover House, which is on Whitehall. And today, in fact, is the Scotland office. She has galloped from there all the way over to Holland House in Kensington. And so she arrives in her very masculine cut riding habit, glowing. Throws herself down flamboyantly on a sofa. She's all sweaty and stuff. It's all absolutely calculated. So Byron goes to Dover House the next morning and Caroline hosts these kind of, they're kind of morning waltzes.
所以拜伦在那里。卡罗琳知道他在那里。墨尔本一家在白厅有一处住所，多佛庄园（Dover House）。事实上，今天那里是苏格兰办公室。她从那里一路骑马飞奔到肯辛顿的荷兰庄园。所以她穿着她那身非常男性化的骑装，容光焕发地到达了。华丽地倒在沙发上。她浑身是汗之类的。这一切绝对是经过计算的。所以拜伦第二天早上去了多佛庄园，卡罗琳举办了那种，它们有点像晨间华尔兹。
Maybe 40, 50 people are invited. They dance and then they have a restorative cold dinner. It's all very grand. It's the invitation everyone wants to have. Byron comes, of course, he can't dance because of his club foot. So he just stands there posing, looking kind of faintly superior. I mean, he's very shy and very nervous because he can't dance at a dance. So it's awful, but this just makes him all the more glamorous. And again, I think one of the ways in which he's massively influential is that he kind of establishes the template of
也许邀请了40、50个人。他们跳舞，然后吃一顿恢复体力的冷餐。这一切都非常隆重。这是每个人都想得到的邀请。拜伦当然来了，但他因为内翻足不能跳舞。所以他只是站在那里摆姿势，看起来有点淡淡的傲慢。我的意思是，他非常害羞和紧张，因为他在舞会上不能跳舞。所以这很糟糕，但这让他显得更加迷人。而且我再次认为，他在很大程度上具有影响力的方式之一是，他建立了一种
cool, of not joining in, of being aloof. Yeah. Standing apart. So all eyes are on him. And I think it's fair to say that the eyes of two particular members of Caroline's extended family are on him. So the first of these, we already mentioned Lady Melbourne, who is Caroline's mother-in-law. And she's a terrible person. She's cynical. She's manipulative. She's amoral. It's said of her that she only has to see a happy marriage and she works to destroy it.
酷的模板，即不参与，保持冷漠。是的。置身事外。所以所有的目光都集中在他身上。而且我认为可以公平地说，卡罗琳大家庭中两个特定成员的目光也集中在他身上。所以第一个，我们已经提到了墨尔本夫人，她是卡罗琳的婆婆。她是个可怕的人。她愤世嫉俗、善于操纵、毫无道德。人们说她只要看到一段幸福的婚姻，就会努力去破坏它。
So she's Madame de Merteuil. Is she in Dangerous Liaisons, that kind of character? Yes, absolutely. So she loves writing letters, bitching about people, trying to kind of cause mischief. And of course, the Marquis de Mertoy has the Vicomte de Valmore. Anyone who's seen the film Dangerous Liaisons will remember that. Yeah. And she's thinking, maybe Byron can be my Valmore.
所以她是梅尔特伊侯爵夫人（Madame de Merteuil）。她是《危险关系》里的那种角色吗？是的，绝对是。所以她喜欢写信，抱怨别人，试图制造麻烦。当然，梅尔特伊侯爵夫人有瓦尔蒙子爵（Vicomte de Valmore）。任何看过电影《危险关系》的人都会记得。是的。她在想，也许拜伦可以成为我的瓦尔蒙。
Who knows? She can use him to basically ruin other people's lives and amuse herself. She's intrigued by him. She knows that Byron is great friends with Lady Holland, who is quite like her. So she knows that Byron has a kind of thing for classy, sophisticated, middle-aged hostesses of salons. So she is going to put out the feelers to him. But there is also another woman there who is much younger, and that is Lady Melbourne's niece, so Caroline Lamb's cousin-in-law. And she's from the northeast,
谁知道呢？她可以利用他来摧毁别人的生活并取悦自己。她对他很感兴趣。她知道拜伦和荷兰夫人（Lady Holland）是好朋友，荷兰夫人和她很像。所以她知道拜伦对那种优雅、世故、中年沙龙女主人情有独钟。所以她要向他伸出触角。但那里还有另一个女人，她年轻得多，那就是墨尔本夫人的侄女，也就是卡罗琳·兰姆的表妹。她来自东北部，
so Dan Jackson land. In fact, Jonathan Wilson land. So they're two of our previous guests for people who don't know what you're talking about. Yes. So she is from a place called Seaham, just down the coast from Sunderland on the Northumbrian coast. And she is called Annabella Milbank. And she is up for her second London season. And I think it's fair to say that she's the opposite of Caroline in almost every way. So she is rounded. She's kind of buxom.
所以是丹·杰克逊（Dan Jackson）的地盘。事实上，是乔纳森·威尔逊（Jonathan Wilson）的地盘。对于不知道你在说什么的人来说，他们是我们之前的两位嘉宾。是的。所以她来自桑德兰海岸边的一个叫西汉姆（Seaham）的地方，在诺森伯兰海岸。她叫安娜贝拉·米尔班克（Annabella Milbank）。她正在参加她的第二个伦敦社交季。而且我认为可以公平地说，她在几乎所有方面都与卡罗琳相反。所以她圆润。她有点丰满。
Right. So she fits the standard of beauty of the time. She does much more. She has a kind of round apple shaped face. It's often described as being. And her character character she is very pious she's precociously good at maths and maths i mean what a weird fact that is she loves maths loves maths big fan of jane austen right and she sits there rather primly and in her journal later
对。所以她符合当时的美的标准。她做的远不止这些。她有一张圆圆的苹果脸。它经常被描述成那样。而且她的性格，她非常虔诚，她在数学方面早熟，数学，我的意思是，这是一个多么奇怪的事实。她喜欢数学，非常喜欢数学，是简·奥斯汀的忠实粉丝，对吧？她坐在那里，相当一本正经，在她的日记里，那天晚上的
that night she affects contempt for all the women who'd been fluttering around byron she says rather priggishly i made no offering at the shrine of Childe Harold. But then she adds, though I shall not refuse the acquaintance if it comes my way. Oh my word. So there you've got the three characters. So you've got the Lady Melbourne. She's nicknamed the Spider. Did you say that, Tom?
晚些时候，她对所有在拜伦身边飞来飞去的女人表示蔑视。她相当自命不凡地说：“我没有在恰尔德·哈罗德的神龛前献祭。”但随后她补充说：“虽然如果机会来了，我也不会拒绝结识。”天哪。所以你有了这三个角色。你有墨尔本夫人。她被昵称为“蜘蛛”。你这么说了吗，汤姆？
She's nicknamed the Spider, yeah. The Spider. You've got Caroline Lamb, her daughter-in-law, who looks like Audrey Hepburn in my mind. And then you've got the other woman who's more sort of buxom annabella who's young and brilliant at maths yeah i mean what havoc i can well imagine what havoc lies in store right so what happens immediately is that caroline completely monopolizes byron she recognizes he doesn't want to dance and so she leads him up to her private quarters and she's had ropes put up the staircase so that he can hold onto it and won't stumble with his club foot. What goes on, we don't know, but three days later he's back and he brings a rose and a
她被昵称为“蜘蛛”，是的。“蜘蛛”。你有卡罗琳·兰姆，她的儿媳，在我脑海中她看起来像奥黛丽·赫本。然后你有另一个女人，更丰满一些的安娜贝拉，她年轻且数学天才。是的，我的意思是，我可以想象会有什么样的浩劫。对，所以接下来发生的事情是，卡罗琳完全垄断了拜伦。她意识到他不想跳舞，所以她把他带到她的私人房间，她在楼梯上装了绳子，这样他就可以扶着它，不会因为内翻足而跌倒。发生了什么，我们不知道，但三天后他回来了，他带来了一朵玫瑰和一朵
carnation and he hands them over and he says, your ladyship, I am told, likes all that is new and rare for the moment. In fact, she will hoard that dead rose for the rest of her life. Her obsession with Byron is something that she will never, ever lose. And Byron likewise is enraptured by her. He writes that he finds her voice very, very erotic. He says it's soft, low, caressing, that was much a beauty and a charm. And he notes that it reminds him of John Edelston, his voice. Is that the bloke that he saved from drowning? Yes, the choir boy who then subsequently had died. But what Byron also likes is her complete lack of kind of cant, you know, cant, hypocrisy, posing morality. Byron hates all that. And Caroline has nothing of it. And so rather injudiciously, he starts to tell her all his
康乃馨，他递给她说：“夫人，我听说您喜欢当下所有新奇和稀有的东西。”事实上，她会把那朵枯萎的玫瑰珍藏一辈子。她对拜伦的痴迷是她永远、永远不会失去的。拜伦同样被她迷住了。他写道，他发现她的声音非常、非常色情。他说它柔和、低沉、充满爱抚，那是一种美和魅力。他注意到这让他想起了约翰·埃德尔斯顿（John Edelston）的声音。那是他从溺水中救出的那个家伙吗？是的，那个后来去世的唱诗班男孩。但拜伦也喜欢她完全没有那种虚伪、做作的道德感。拜伦讨厌这一切。而卡罗琳一点也没有。所以他相当轻率地开始告诉她他所有的
secrets. He tells her all about her money problems. And Caroline rather sweetly writes to him and says, look, I've got my jewels. I'll sell them. I'll give you all the money. And he also starts talking to her about his homoerotic yearnings. And in response to that, she puts on her page outfit, actually the livery that she had designed for her own pages. She starts wearing that. She's like, I'll dress as a boy for you, basically. Yes, but not just a boy, a servant. And she renames one of her own pages, Rushton, who had been the page boy who had gone with Byron on his travels.
秘密。他告诉她所有关于他金钱方面的问题。卡罗琳相当甜蜜地写信给他，说：“看，我有我的珠宝。我会卖掉它们。我会给你所有的钱。”他还开始和她谈论他同性恋的渴望。作为回应，她穿上了她的侍童装，实际上是她为自己的侍童设计的制服。她开始穿那套衣服。她就像是：“我基本上会为你打扮成男孩。”是的，不仅是男孩，还是仆人。她重新命名了她自己的一个侍童，拉什顿（Rushton），他就是那个和拜伦一起旅行的侍童。
Okay. And he went to Portugal. Yeah. So there's a kind of weird minuet going on. There are kind of taboos and gender differences and class differences, and they're all being played with. And it's all kind of taboos and gender differences and class differences and they're all being played with and it's all kind of very titillating but also obviously incredibly dangerous because adding spice to the mixture is the fact that it's an adulterous affair yeah william
好的。他去了葡萄牙。是的。所以有一种奇怪的小步舞曲在进行。有各种禁忌、性别差异和阶级差异，它们都被玩弄了。这一切都非常挑逗，但也显然极其危险，因为增加这种混合物刺激性的是，这是一段通奸关系。是的，威廉·
melbourne is a very very distinguished figure but also i mean he's he's like it's not just they're having an affair i mean people have affairs in regency lond. It's an affair in which she's dressing up as a page boy. If you're being generous in Regency England, you would say these were eccentric tastes. If you're being ungenerous, you would say they were terrible tastes. They were criminal. They are. Byron is embarrassed by them and I think essentially is able to imply that this is Caroline's doing. Oh, okay.
墨尔本是一个非常、非常杰出的人物，但我的意思是，他就像是……这不仅仅是他们有外遇，我的意思是，人们在摄政时期的伦敦会有外遇。这是一段她打扮成侍童的外遇。如果你在摄政时期的英国表现得宽容，你会说这些是古怪的品味。如果你表现得不宽容，你会说这是糟糕的品味。它们是犯罪的。它们确实是。拜伦对它们感到尴尬，我认为他基本上能够暗示这是卡罗琳所为。哦，好的。
So he is not saying these are my tastes. The implication is Caroline is doing this because, okay. So he is not saying, these are my tastes. The implication is Caroline is doing this because she's a bit mad, she's a bit cracked. And the more the scandal of it builds, the more anxious about it it becomes, the more desperate he becomes actually to kind of try and break it off. So that's counterintuitive. Not really, because he is the hero of the hour. He's the great object of female erotic obsession. I don't think it would cross anyone's mind that he's anything other than a breaker of women's hearts. And Caroline is already notorious as an eccentric. The blame for it, and also, I mean, this reflects the imbalance of power between men and women, that it's usually women who get blamed in an adulterous relationship. Yeah. And I think also Byron is genuinely more conventional in his social attitudes than Caroline is. I mean, she's of higher rank and the higher rank you are, the easier it becomes.
所以他不是在说这些是我的品味。暗示是卡罗琳在做这些事，因为……好的。所以他不是在说，这些是我的品味。暗示是卡罗琳在做这些事，因为她有点疯，有点精神失常。丑闻闹得越大，他对此就越焦虑，他实际上就越绝望地想要尝试结束这段关系。所以这违反直觉。并不完全是，因为他是当下的英雄。他是女性色情痴迷的伟大对象。我不认为有人会想到他除了是一个伤透女人心的男人之外还有别的身份。而卡罗琳作为怪人已经臭名昭著。对此的指责，而且，我的意思是，这反映了男女之间权力的不平衡，通常是女性在通奸关系中受到指责。是的。而且我认为拜伦在社会态度上确实比卡罗琳更传统。我的意思是，她的地位更高，地位越高，事情就越容易。
He's more insecure about his social position, I suppose. Completely. And also Caroline is starting to behave in an alarming way because basically she is stalking him. You know, Byron has a lot of women who are stalking him, but Caroline is pushing it to extremes. So in her disguise as a page boy, she breaks into his rooms and starts rifling through his drawers, probably looking for evidence that he's having relationships with other women. A few weeks later, she disguises herself not as a boy, but as a man, breaks into Byron's bedroom. Byron says, please leave. She refuses, manages to persuade Byron to elope
我想他对自己的社会地位更不自信。完全是。而且卡罗琳开始表现出一种令人担忧的方式，因为基本上她在跟踪他。你知道，拜伦有很多女人在跟踪他，但卡罗琳把它推向了极端。所以她伪装成侍童，闯入他的房间，开始翻箱倒柜，可能是在寻找他和其他女人有关系的证据。几周后，她不伪装成男孩，而是伪装成男人，闯入拜伦的卧室。拜伦说，请离开。她拒绝了，设法说服拜伦和她私奔。
with her. I mean, and Byron, I think is quite passive in his relationship with women, oddly. And Byron kind of says, okay, I'll do that. And he's only stopped from doing it by Hobhouse, who turns up and Hobhouse is very much not the kind of person to be impressed by someone like Caroline Lamb. Yeah. She sounds, frankly, Tom, a bit of a crackpot and actually this- Bit of a package. Yeah. The next bit of behavior- Yes. May confirm this in people's minds. a crackpot and actually this bit of a package yeah the next bit of behavior yes may confirm this in people's minds so now it's august 1812 and she sends byron a cutting of her pubic hair and what is alarming for byron is that with them there is a knowing illusion to uh john edelston
我的意思是，而且拜伦，我觉得在与女性的关系中相当被动，奇怪的是。拜伦说，好吧，我会那样做。他只是被霍布豪斯（Hobhouse）阻止了，霍布豪斯出现了，而霍布豪斯绝不是那种会被卡罗琳·兰姆这样的人打动的人。是的。坦率地说，汤姆，她听起来有点疯，实际上这——有点麻烦。是的。接下来的行为——是的，可能会在人们心中证实这一点。有点疯，实际上这——有点麻烦。是的。接下来的行为——是的，可能会在人们心中证实这一点。所以现在是1812年8月，她寄给拜伦一撮她的阴毛，而让拜伦感到担忧的是，它们中有一种对约翰·埃德尔斯顿的知情暗示。
does this remind you of john edelston byron is that what's what's the say no so byron had written poems to john edelston under the name of theusa, so a girl's name. And Caroline Lamb says, this is from the person you love as much as Theusa. So Byron is kind of thinking, there's a faint whiff of blackmail here. And three days later, she vanishes from Dover House, kind of runs out, yelling at her husband that she's running off with Byron. William Lamb completely loses it and says, go and be damned. He won't have you. And he's right. Byron doesn't. He manages to persuade Caroline to go back to Melbourne House. And then he sits down, he writes a letter breaking off the affair. I mean, he's kind, but he's absolutely firm. So Tom, how long has it been going on for this affair?
这让你想起约翰·埃德尔斯顿了吗，拜伦，这是什么意思？不。所以拜伦曾以“瑟萨”（Theusa）的名字给约翰·埃德尔斯顿写过诗，这是一个女孩的名字。卡罗琳·兰姆说，这是来自你像爱瑟萨一样爱的人。所以拜伦有点在想，这里有一丝勒索的味道。三天后，她从多佛庄园消失了，跑了出去，对她丈夫大喊大叫，说她要和拜伦私奔。威廉·兰姆彻底崩溃了，说：“去吧，去下地狱吧。他不会要你的。”他是对的。拜伦没有。他设法说服卡罗琳回到墨尔本庄园。然后他坐下来，写了一封信结束了这段恋情。我的意思是，他很客气，但他非常坚定。所以汤姆，这段恋情持续了多久？
About five months. Five months. So it's reasonably short, by the standards of such things. Yeah, it is short. And it's about the average length standards of such things yeah it is short and it's about the average length that byron has his affairs okay he seems to feel claustrophobic if he has a relationship that lasts longer than that and what byron also hasn't told caroline is that he has been writing about her behind her back to her detested mother-in-law the spider lady melbourne right so this is a twist and basically he's's been asking Lady Melbourne for help in breaking up the affair. And Lady Melbourne decides that the only way that the affair can probably be broken up
大约五个月。五个月。所以按照这种事情的标准，它相当短。是的，它很短。而且大约是拜伦恋情的平均长度。好的。他似乎如果一段关系持续时间超过那个长度就会感到幽闭恐惧。而且拜伦没有告诉卡罗琳的是，他一直在她背后向她那令人厌恶的婆婆——蜘蛛墨尔本夫人写信。对，所以这是一个转折，基本上他一直在请求墨尔本夫人帮助结束这段恋情。墨尔本夫人认为，结束这段恋情的唯一方法可能是
is if Byron gets married. Yeah. And Lady Melbourne suggests her niece, Annabella Milbank. Okay. So Lady Melbourne, I mean, she's so dangerous liaisons. I mean, it's unbelievable, actually. I mean, it's like a kind of reenactment of it. She's basically pimping out her niece,
拜伦结婚。是的。墨尔本夫人建议她的侄女，安娜贝拉·米尔班克。好的。所以墨尔本夫人，我的意思是，她太《危险关系》了。我的意思是，这令人难以置信，实际上。我的意思是，这就像是它的重演。她基本上是在拉皮条，推销她的侄女，
the apple-cheeked maths enthusiast, in order to break up Byron with her daughter-in-law. Yeah, she absolutely is. And a bit like Valmore, it is beyond my control. Yeah. He, I think, is quite submissive to Lady Melbourne. He basically finds it very difficult to oppose
那个苹果脸的数学爱好者，为了让他和她儿媳分手。是的，她绝对是。而且有点像瓦尔蒙，这超出了我的控制。是的。他，我认为，对墨尔本夫人相当顺从。他基本上发现很难反对
what she suggests. And it's fair to say that he is intrigued by Annabella. He recognises the role that he is playing in her imagination. So he writes to Lady Melbourne, Miss Milbank is too good for a fallen spirit to know or wish to know. I should like her more if she were less perfect, he adds. So I think that that basically sums up the relationship. Right. She's too good for him. Yeah. But also that Annabella is attracted to him precisely because he seems to be a fallen spirit and her fantasy in the long run will be to try and redeem him. And he doesn't want to be redeemed, presumably?
她建议的事情。而且可以公平地说，他对安娜贝拉很感兴趣。他认识到他在她的想象中扮演的角色。所以他写信给墨尔本夫人：“米尔班克小姐对于一个堕落的灵魂来说太好了，不配认识或希望认识。如果她不那么完美，我会更喜欢她，”他补充道。所以我认为这基本上总结了这段关系。对。她对他来说太好了。是的。但安娜贝拉被他吸引也正是因为他看起来像一个堕落的灵魂，而她长期的幻想将是试图救赎他。而他不想被救赎，大概？
Kind of, but I think also he is aware that it's slightly ridiculous as well. I mean, he poses as a fallen spirit, but he's also aware that it's funny. Yeah. And Annabella never gets this. Annabella has no sense of humour whatsoever. So he's persuaded by Lady Melbourne to make a marriage proposal. And he does this in October 1812. Caroline is still kind of hovering around like a butterfly beating at the window. So he sends Annabella the offer. Annabella ponders it. She very, very soberly writes down a list of all his pluses and
某种程度上，但我认为他也意识到这有点荒谬。我的意思是，他假装是一个堕落的灵魂，但他同时也意识到这很有趣。是的。而安娜贝拉从来没有明白这一点。安娜贝拉根本没有幽默感。所以他被墨尔本夫人说服去求婚。他在1812年10月这样做了。卡罗琳仍然像一只拍打着窗户的蝴蝶一样徘徊。所以他给安娜贝拉发了求婚信。安娜贝拉考虑了一下。她非常、非常清醒地写下了一份他所有优点和
minuses. And then three days later writes back to him saying, no, I don't think that we're suited. Oh, good for her. She's made the right choice. Lady Melbourne, absolutely furious. You know, who is this little prig? Right. To turn down this tremendous offer. But Byron seems relieved and he memorably describes Annabella as my princess of parallelograms and astutely comments we are two parallel lines prolonged to infinity side by side but never to meet would appeal to a maths enthusiast that analogy completely but of course as caroline's snubbing him at the ball had piqued his interest so annabella turning down his marriage proposal also piques his interest i
缺点的清单。然后三天后回信说，不，我不认为我们合适。哦，她做得对。她做出了正确的选择。墨尔本夫人，绝对愤怒。你知道，这个小伪君子是谁？对，竟然拒绝了这么好的提议。但拜伦似乎松了一口气，他令人难忘地将安娜贝拉描述为“我的平行四边形公主”，并敏锐地评论道：“我们是两条延长到无限的平行线，并排而行，但永远不会相交。”这比喻会吸引数学爱好者。完全是，但当然，正如卡罗琳在舞会上对他视而不见激起了他的兴趣一样，安娜贝拉拒绝他的求婚也激起了他的兴趣。我
mean it kind of makes him more interested in her i think than he would otherwise have been right and definitely annabella remains fascinated by him and she starts writing to him despite the fact that she's turned him down and she justifies this as her christian duty you know he is a fallen spirit she has a duty to redeem him byron finds this hilarious forwards all her letters to Lady Melbourne. Oh God. Even as he's also keeping Lady Melbourne abreast with all his other affairs. So he gets off the chaise long, rushes up, writes it up for Lady Melbourne. I mean, it's very, very dangerous liaisons. And yet all the while in his private journal, which he's not showing to Lady Melbourne,
意思是，这让他对她比原本更感兴趣，我想。对，而且安娜贝拉确实对他保持着迷，尽管她拒绝了他，她还是开始给他写信，她把这解释为她的基督徒义务。你知道，他是一个堕落的灵魂，她有义务救赎他。拜伦觉得这太搞笑了，把她所有的信都转发给了墨尔本夫人。天哪。即使他同时也让墨尔本夫人了解他所有的其他恋情。所以他从躺椅上下来，冲过去，为墨尔本夫人写下来。我的意思是，这非常、非常《危险关系》。然而，在他私人的日记里，他没有给墨尔本夫人看，
he is very complimentary about Annabella. He calls her a very superior woman. And you could think that's both a criticism perhaps, as well as a compliment. But he's respectful of her. And I think his sense of her appeal is enhanced for him by two factors. The first of these is that Caroline is still very much on the scene and she's getting worse and worse. She's still stalking him. Stalking him, bombarding him with letters.
他对安娜贝拉非常赞赏。他称她为“一位非常优秀的女性”。你可以认为这既是一种批评，也是一种赞美。但他尊重她。而且我认为他对她吸引力的感觉被两个因素增强了。第一个是卡罗琳仍然在现场，而且她变得越来越糟。她还在跟踪他。跟踪他，用信件轰炸他。
July 1813. So this is a year on from their first relationship she goes to a ball byron is there she gashes herself with a piece of broken glass then stabs herself with a pair of scissors you know a massive massive scandal blood everywhere although as lady melbourne who leads her home notes writing about it to byron she'd made sure that none of the wounds were very severe right implication being that it's all done for show. But it's reported in all the newspapers. And so the scandal of it now is very, very public. It's kind of reaching those provincial towns that you were talking about, you know, asking, do they know about Brighton? I mean, yes, everybody in the country knows about
1813年7月。所以这是他们第一次关系一年后，她去参加一个舞会，拜伦也在那里，她用一块碎玻璃割伤了自己，然后用一把剪刀刺伤了自己，你知道，一场巨大的、巨大的丑闻，到处都是血。虽然正如带她回家的墨尔本夫人在写给拜伦的信中所指出的那样，她确保了伤口都不严重。对，暗示这一切都是为了做戏。但它被所有的报纸报道了。所以现在的丑闻非常、非常公开。它有点传到了你刚才谈到的那些省份城镇，你知道，问，他们知道布莱顿吗？我的意思是，是的，全国每个人都知道
it. So Byron is feeling very persecuted by this. There is simultaneously a second crisis brewing. And this is the second of the relationships that we talked about, the second of the three relationships that we talked about. So Caroline's the first and now the second. Because even as all this is going on, Byron reports to his friend Thomas More, the poet, who will be the first to write his biography, I am at this moment in a far more serious and entirely new scrape
这件事。所以拜伦感到非常受此迫害。同时，第二场危机正在酝酿。这就是我们谈到的三段关系中的第二段。所以卡罗琳是第一段，现在是第二段。因为即使这一切都在发生，拜伦向他的朋友、诗人托马斯·摩尔（Thomas More）报告说，他将是第一个写他传记的人，“我此刻正处于一个比过去12个月里任何时候都更严重、全新的困境中。”这话说得很有分量。我认为把这描述为“困境”，困境是指你在公立学校，爬出窗户去邻近的果园偷苹果。接下来发生的事情不是这个。我不想剧透，汤姆。所以听众可能记得，在第一集里，
than any of the last 12 months. And that is saying a good deal. I think to describe this as a scrape, a scrape is when you're at public school and you've climbed out of the windows to get some apples from a neighbouring orchard. What will follow is not this. I don't want to give the game away, Tom. So listeners may remember that in the first episode,
我们谈到了“疯杰克”（Mad Jack），拜伦的父亲，他最终娶了拜伦的母亲凯瑟琳·戈登。但在那之前，他曾与卡马森侯爵夫人（Marchioness of Carmarthen）私奔，她是乔治·奥斯本（George Osborne）的远亲。所以疯杰克和卡马森侯爵夫人有三个孩子。其中两个死了，但其中一个，一个女儿，奥古斯塔（Augusta），活了下来。她仍然在现场。她嫁给了一个赌徒和一个绝对的败类，
we talked about Mad Jack, Byron's father, and he ends up marrying Byron's mother, Catherine Gordon. But before that, he had eloped with the Marchioness of Carmarthen, distant relative of George Osborne. So Mad Jack and the Marchioness of Carmarthen have three children. Two of them die, but one of them, a daughter, Augusta, survives. And she is still very much on the scene. She has married a gambler and an absolute reprobate,
所以非常符合家族传统，叫李上校（Colonel Lee）。她住在纽马克特附近，所以非常，你知道，对赛马和一切都很棒，在一个叫“六英里底”（Six Mile Bottom）的地方，这是一个非常滑稽的居住地。是的，当然。而且她的丈夫欠博彩公司巨额债务，所以她在1813年夏天来找她哥哥帮忙应付法警，她非常害羞，是的，她不时尚，有点乡土气，是的，你知道，从童年起她就崇拜拜伦，拜伦也崇拜她。而且。拜伦崇拜她。而且在身体上，拜伦发现她非常有吸引力。
so very much running in the family, called Colonel Lee. And she lives near Newmarket, so very, you know, brilliant for horse racing and everything, at a place called Six Mile Bottom, which is a very comic place for her to live. Yeah, of course. and her husband is massively in debt to bookies and so she comes up in the summer of 1813 to ask her brother for help with the bailiffs and she is she's very shy yeah she's not fashionable bit provincial yeah you know from childhood she has adored byron byron has adored her and. Byron has adored her. And physically, Byron finds her very attractive.
她实际上是卡罗琳的对立面。所以拜伦，后来在《唐璜》中，他把奥古斯塔描绘成君士坦丁堡后宫里的一个奴隶女孩，叫杜杜（Dudu）。他形容她是一个“昏昏欲睡的维纳斯”，有点大只、慵懒、懒散，但有一种会让你疯狂的美。所以有一种身体上的吸引力，但也有拜伦感到的一种神秘纽带，是的，他们是兄妹，他们共享一种被诅咒的血液。事实是，奥古斯塔以一种没有人能做到的方式理解拜伦和他的行为动机。她能让他笑，她很擅长让他
She's actually the opposite of Caroline. So Byron, later in Don Juan, he gives a portrait of Augusta as a slave girl in the harem in Constantinople called Dudu. And he describes her as a kind of sleepy Venus, somewhat large and languishing and lazy, yet of a beauty that would drive you crazy. So there's a physical attraction, but there's also's also byron feels a kind of mystic bond yeah that they their brother and sister they share a cursed blood and the truth is that augusta understands byron and what makes him tick in a way that no one else does she can make him laugh she's good at kind of getting
摆脱那种戏剧性的抑郁发作，她让他感到安全和被爱，这是其他人无法做到的。没有争吵。没有嫉妒。没有在舞会上用剪刀刺伤自己或任何类似的事情。所以他感到不安全。他感到不快乐。他最终和她上了床。哦，我的意思是，汤姆。
him out of his melodramatic fits of depression she makes him feel secure and loved in a way that no one else does. There are no scenes. There are no jealousy. There's no stabbing herself with scissors at balls or any of that kind of thing. And so he's feeling insecure. He's feeling unhappy. He ends up in bed with her. Oh, I mean, Tom.
所以正如你所说，一个困境。一个困境。所以，我的意思是，同父异母的兄妹。这太糟糕了。这是糟糕的定义。当然，他们俩都知道他们的父亲曾与他的妹妹有过一段恋情。所以再次，有一种非常拜伦式的做法。这个家庭到底怎么了？
So as you say, a scrape. A scrape. So, I mean, half brother and half sister. It's poor form. It is the definition of poor form. And of course, both of them are aware that their father had had an affair with his sister. So again, there's this sense it's a very Byronic thing to do. What's going on with this family?
正如你所说，这是一种擦边球。擦边球。我的意思是，同父异母的兄妹。这很不体面。这简直就是不体面的代名词。当然，他们俩都知道他们的父亲曾与自己的亲姐妹有过一段私情。所以，这又给人一种非常拜伦式行为的感觉。这个家庭到底是怎么回事？
And his father had eloped with Augusta's mother. So all that August, 1813, Byron and Augusta are discussing, well, we should elope. And Lady Melbourne has kind of picked up on this because of course, Byron can't resist telling her. And she's like, no, don't. Because obviously, I mean, you know, eloping with your sister. Why had he told her? Why would you tell somebody whose nickname was the spider that you were having an affair with your own sister? I know. I mean, just thank God he wasn't on social media. I mean, imagine him on Instagram. Oh, bonkers.
他的父亲曾与奥古斯塔的母亲私奔。因此，在1813年8月的整个时间里，拜伦和奥古斯塔一直在讨论，嗯，我们应该私奔。墨尔本夫人对此有所察觉，因为拜伦当然忍不住告诉了她。她说，不，别这么做。因为很明显，我的意思是，你知道，和你的妹妹私奔。他为什么要告诉她？你为什么要告诉一个绰号叫“蜘蛛”的人，说你正在和自己的亲妹妹发生关系？我知道。我的意思是，谢天谢地他没用社交媒体。我是说，想象一下他在Instagram上。哦，简直疯了。
Terrible. So anyway, Augusta and Byron, by the end of August, have decided better of it. So no elopement, but they do continue their affair. So that's that kind of Christmas of 1813, New Year, and then they go off together to Newstead. So the baronial pile that is Byron's inheritance is Lord Byron. And it's very, very cold and wintry, deep snow, difficult for them to get there. And when they arrive there, it's as though they are walled in by the snow. So the great fires are blazing, torches, candles, and they're there for weeks. And from what both of them write, it seems to have been the happiest period in both their lives.
太可怕了。总之，到8月底，奥古斯塔和拜伦打消了这个念头。所以没有私奔，但他们确实继续了他们的婚外情。这就是1813年的圣诞节、新年，然后他们一起去了纽斯特德。那是拜伦继承的男爵府邸，也就是拜伦勋爵的家。那里非常非常冷，冬意浓浓，大雪纷飞，他们很难到达那里。当他们到达时，感觉就像被大雪围困了一样。于是大火熊熊燃烧，火把、蜡烛，他们在那儿待了几个星期。从他们两人的书信来看，这似乎是他们一生中最幸福的时光。
They clearly ecstatically happy. And the atmospherics of being in this ancestral pile, I mean, incredibly romantic in every way. You know, the snow melts. It's February. He has to go back to London. And he's aware that he's kind of teetering on the edge of massive, massive scandal. And he takes kind of very, very flashy rooms, Dominic, and he takes them in the Albany,
他们显然欣喜若狂。身处这座祖宅的氛围，我的意思是，在各方面都极其浪漫。你知道，雪融化了。已经是二月了。他必须回到伦敦。他意识到自己正处于巨大丑闻的边缘。多米尼克，他租了一些非常非常显眼的房间，他在奥尔巴尼租的，
which was originally called Melbourne House. And Lady Melbourne had spent her first years as a bride there with Lord Melbourne. They then sold it up and moved to Dover House. But of course, a similarly byronic figure very in the long run will move in and live there in the same block and that of course is edward heath edward heath great star of our 1974 series and probably is it fair to say the least byronic person who's ever lived i think i think it is i think yeah so byron settles in there he has the best set of rooms in the albany he writes to
那里最初被称为墨尔本大厦。墨尔本夫人曾作为新娘在那里与墨尔本勋爵度过了最初的几年。后来他们把它卖掉，搬到了多佛大厦。但当然，从长远来看，一个类似的拜伦式人物会搬进去住在同一个街区，那当然就是爱德华·希思，爱德华·希思是我们1974年系列节目的伟大明星，可能可以说是有史以来最不具拜伦气质的人，我想是的，我想是的。所以拜伦在那里安顿下来，他拥有奥尔巴尼最好的房间，他写信给
melbourne i've split up with augusta but he then commits a terrible i mean unbelievable mistake he tells caroline lamb it's like he can't help but talk about it he's so obsessed by it wow he wants to share it with caroline tells the very person who's stalking him oh by the way i'm sleeping with my sister yeah and so caroline writes back i love that augusta with my heart because she is yours and is dear to you caroline then tells lady melbourne wow byron's having an affair with his sister and lady melbourne hits the roof i mean she says what are you doing telling caroline i mean are you mad so lady melbourne's not cross that it's happening she's crossed that he's told caroline she is crossed that it's happening but she's particularly furious that he's told Caroline. Partly, I think, because she knows, you know,
墨尔本说我跟奥古斯塔分手了，但他随后犯了一个可怕的，我的意思是令人难以置信的错误，他告诉了卡罗琳·兰姆，他好像忍不住要谈论这件事，他对此太着迷了，哇，他想和卡罗琳分享，告诉那个一直在跟踪他的人，哦，顺便说一下，我正在和我的妹妹睡觉，是的，于是卡罗琳回信说，我全心全意地爱着奥古斯塔，因为她是你的，对你来说很珍贵，卡罗琳随后告诉了墨尔本夫人，哇，拜伦正在和他的妹妹发生关系，墨尔本夫人大发雷霆，我的意思是她说你为什么要告诉卡罗琳，我的意思是你是疯了吗？所以墨尔本夫人并不是因为这件事发生而生气，她是气他告诉了卡罗琳，她对这件事发生感到生气，但她特别愤怒的是他告诉了卡罗琳。部分原因，我想，是因为她知道，你知道，
don't tell Caroline, she'll tell everyone. But also because it's her confidence. So she feels offended. And so they agree, you know, there's nothing for it. He's got to get married. And Lady Melbourne says, well, what about Annabella pimping her out again? And Byron knows that this is possible because Annabella has invited him to see him. In the Northeast, yeah. And this has been done with her parents' permission. And Byron writes back and says, yeah, okay. But then having done that, he prevaricates.
别告诉卡罗琳，她会告诉所有人的。但也因为这是对她的信任。所以她感到被冒犯了。于是他们达成一致，你知道，别无他法。他必须结婚。墨尔本夫人说，那么安娜贝拉怎么样？又在帮他拉皮条了？拜伦知道这是可能的，因为安娜贝拉邀请他去见她。在东北部，是的。这是在她父母的许可下完成的。拜伦回信说，好吧，可以。但做完这些后，他却支支吾吾。
He's obviously thinking, yeah, I can see why it would work from one point of view, but from another, I don't really think she's my kind. I don't think it'll really work out and so they're endlessly writing and annabella writes to him you do not appear to be the person whom i ought to select as my guide my support my example on earth with a view still to immortality so they've been discussing should they marry and she's writing and saying i think you'll be bad for my soul and as soon as as soon as she says this be bad for my soul. And as soon as she says this, he's like, great, I'm in. As soon as she says, I don't think we should marry.
他显然在想，是的，从一个角度看我明白为什么这行得通，但从另一个角度看，我真的不认为她是我的菜。我不认为这真的会成功，所以他们没完没了地写信，安娜贝拉写信给他，你看起来不像是我应该选择作为我在地球上的向导、支持和榜样的人，以期获得永生。所以他们一直在讨论他们是否应该结婚，而她写信说，我想你会对我的灵魂有害。而一旦她说了这句话，一旦她说了这句话，他就想，太好了，我加入。一旦她说，我不认为我们应该结婚。
He writes and says, yeah, let's get married. And Annabella immediately is so happy to get that, that she writes the same letter both to Albany and to Newstead because she's not sure where he's going to be. And in fact, the letter reaches Byron at Newstead on the 17th of September. And he is there with Augusta. And he opens the letter, he reads it, and Annabella has written, this is a moment of joy which I have too much despaired of ever experiencing. I dared not believe it possible. Byron reads it, and then he hands over the letter to Augusta, and he had shown
他写信说，是的，我们结婚吧。安娜贝拉立刻高兴得不得了，她给奥尔巴尼和纽斯特德都写了同样的信，因为她不确定他会在哪里。事实上，这封信在9月17日送达了纽斯特德的拜伦手中。他和奥古斯塔在那里。他打开信，读了它，安娜贝拉写道，这是一个我从未敢奢望经历的快乐时刻。我不敢相信这是可能的。拜伦读了信，然后把信交给了奥古斯塔，他之前已经给
Augusta his proposal of marriage before he had posted it. So Augusta knows exactly what's going on and approves it. Augusta takes the letter, glances at it, looks up at Byron, sees that Byron is deathly pale and Byron's comment on it, it never rains, but it pours. What a bizarre story. I don't think I'm giving anything away when I say that things will get more complicated, weirder in the second half, and they won't end happily for everybody ever after, will they, Tom? No. Come back after the break to find just how weird things get.
奥古斯塔看了他的求婚信，在他寄出之前。所以奥古斯塔完全知道发生了什么并表示赞同。奥古斯塔接过信，扫了一眼，抬头看着拜伦，看到拜伦脸色惨白，拜伦对此的评论是，祸不单行。多么离奇的故事。我想当我说事情在下半场会变得更复杂、更古怪时，我并没有剧透什么，而且结局对每个人来说都不会幸福，对吧，汤姆？不。休息后回来，看看事情变得有多古怪。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们会揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. He had been expected for the two preceding days. My mother was impatient, which had not suffered any interruption since the time that I accepted the offer of marriage. I was sitting in my own room, reading, when I heard the carriage. I put out the candles, deliberated what should be done, resolved to meet him first alone. It was so arranged. He was in the drawing room, standing by the side of the chimney piece. He did not move forwards as I approached towards the fireplace. There was a silence. He broke it. It is a long time since we have met in an undertone. My reply was hardly articulate.
那是therestisentertainment.com。人们已经期待他两天了。我母亲很不耐烦，自从我接受了求婚以来，这种不耐烦就没有中断过。我正坐在自己的房间里看书，这时我听到了马车的声音。我吹灭了蜡烛，考虑该做什么，决定先单独见他。事情就是这样安排的。他在客厅里，站在壁炉旁。当我走向壁炉时，他没有向前走。一片寂静。他打破了沉默。我们已经很久没见了，他低声说道。我的回答几乎含糊不清。
So that was Annabella Milbank remembering the moment that Lord Byron arrived at Seaham on the evening of the 1st of November, 1814. She has finally accepted his proposal of marriage. And Tom, the happy lovebird. Yes. Yeah. Surprise me. Tell me that it all ends really happily. Well, the stay is a bit of a disaster. Actually, Byron gets on all right with Annabella. They seem to have been quite happy. They go for kind of walks on the coast and hold hands and all that kind of thing. But he doesn't really get on with his mother-in-law, Lady Milbank. Although that said, I mean, again, he quite likes his father-in-law, Sir Ralph Milbank, who's a Whig like Byron, very opposed to the slave trade. He's a kind of bluff industrialist
所以那是安娜贝拉·米尔班克回忆拜伦勋爵于1814年11月1日晚上抵达西汉姆的那一刻。她终于接受了他的求婚。汤姆，这对幸福的爱情鸟。是的。是的。给我个惊喜。告诉我结局真的很幸福。嗯，这次停留简直是一场灾难。事实上，拜伦和安娜贝拉相处得还不错。他们似乎很幸福。他们去海岸散步，手牵手之类的。但他和他的岳母米尔班克夫人相处得并不好。话虽如此，我的意思是，他还是很喜欢他的岳父拉尔夫·米尔班克爵士，他像拜伦一样是辉格党人，非常反对奴隶贸易。他是一个直率的实业家，
as well. So he's using Stevenson's rockets to take coal from the coal mines that he owns up to Sunderland. So that's very exciting. And Dominic, he's a lover of all things English and hates the French. Oh, yeah. Byron wouldn't like that, but you would have liked that. So if I married Annabella Milbank, it would all be suspended. Basically, the problem is that Byron finds CM
也是。所以他正在使用斯蒂芬森的火箭号火车将他拥有的煤矿里的煤运到桑德兰。这非常令人兴奋。多米尼克，他热爱所有英国的东西，讨厌法国人。哦，是的。拜伦不会喜欢那样，但你会喜欢的。所以如果我娶了安娜贝拉·米尔班克，这一切都会被搁置。基本上，问题在于拜伦觉得西汉姆
incredibly dull. And I think it reminds him of his childhood in Aberdeen. You know, he hates the kind of northerly provincialism. And so he, as well as going for walks with Annabella, he starts exploring her in more intimate ways. And of course, he gives a graphic account of this to Lady Melbourne. Oh, for God's sake. Why would you tell Lady Melbourne that?
极其无聊。我想这让他想起了他在阿伯丁的童年。你知道，他讨厌那种北方的省份气息。所以，除了和安娜贝拉散步，他开始以更亲密的方式探索她。当然，他向墨尔本夫人详细描述了这一点。哦，看在上帝的份上。你为什么要告诉墨尔本夫人那个？
Reports that her passions are stronger than we supposed. So they've obviously been discussing it in some detail. But Annabella stops byron from going too far which annoys byron a lot right and so he stays two weeks there and then he heads back and where do you think he heads he heads straight for six mile bottom and augusta is that physical relationship still continuing do we know unclear but i think probably right so i mean you may well wonder why does the marriage go ahead when it's clearly going to be a disaster? And I think that on Byron's side, he does have feelings
报告说她的激情比我们想象的要强烈。所以他们显然已经详细讨论过了。但安娜贝拉阻止了拜伦做得太过分，这让拜伦非常恼火，对吧？所以他在那里待了两周，然后他回去了，你认为他去了哪里？他径直去了六英里底，奥古斯塔在那里。那种身体关系还在继续吗？我们知道吗？不清楚，但我认为大概是的。所以，我的意思是，你可能很想知道，既然婚姻显然会是一场灾难，为什么还要继续？我认为在拜伦这边，他确实对
for Annabella. I think he admires her. I think there's kind of elements of love there. There's also the fact that all the marriage contracts have been drawn up. So Byron's lawyer, Hanson, has gone and done all that. So difficult to break it. It's been announced in the press. I mean, it would be very embarrassing. And I think that, you know, we talked about how Byron is quite passive in the face of particularly relationships with women. I think there's a kind of mixture of fatalism about it. And of course, a dread of basically what will Caroline do? He's kind of anxious about that as well.
安娜贝拉有感情。我想他钦佩她。我想其中有爱的成分。还有所有婚前协议都已经起草好的事实。所以拜伦的律师汉森已经完成了所有这些工作。所以很难打破它。它已经在媒体上宣布了。我的意思是，那会非常尴尬。而且我认为，你知道，我们谈到了拜伦在面对女性关系时是多么被动。我认为这其中有一种宿命论的混合。当然，还有对卡罗琳会做什么的恐惧？他对此也感到焦虑。
Because Caroline's message to him on learning of the engagement is to say, I love you as a sister feels, as your Augusta feels for you. So that's Caroline saying, I know about you and Augusta as well. Yeah. So basically I think Byron feels, well, if I marry Annabella, then it will just look like Caroline's mad. Yeah. I mean, but she's by now got this colossal dossier on him. She has. She's got all the stuff colossal dossier on him. She has. She's got all the stuff for the bloke in Cambridge.
因为卡罗琳在得知订婚后给他的信息是说，我像姐妹一样爱你，就像你的奥古斯塔对你一样。所以那是卡罗琳在说，我也知道你和奥古斯塔的事。是的。所以基本上我认为拜伦觉得，好吧，如果我娶了安娜贝拉，那么看起来就像卡罗琳疯了。是的。我的意思是，但她现在已经有了关于他的巨额档案。她有了。她有了关于他的巨额档案。她有了。她有了那个剑桥家伙的所有东西。
She's got the stuff for this sister. That's a terrible thing to have hanging over you. Right. So if you marry a kind of pious mathematician, I mean, you know, she's the kind of beard, I guess.
她有了关于这个妹妹的东西。这真是一件可怕的事情。对。所以如果你娶了一个虔诚的数学家，我的意思是，你知道，她就是那种掩护，我想。
Right. And Annabella, I mean, I think she is seduced by his beauty and fame. I mean, she denies it, but she clearly is. She's clearly very,
对。而安娜贝拉，我的意思是，我认为她被他的美貌和名声所诱惑。我的意思是，她否认了，但她显然是。她显然非常，
very obsessed by him. And Byron, in due course, after the failure of their marriage, spoiler alert, he writes cruelly, but I think very accurately, that she married me from vanity and the hope of reforming
非常迷恋他。而拜伦，在他们的婚姻失败后，剧透警告，他残忍地写道，但我认为非常准确，她嫁给我出于虚荣和想要改造
and fixing me. Golly, that's very modern, isn't it? I mean, there he can see that she wanted to fix him, to reform him, and he knows it's not going to work. And again, that's the kind of, you know, that's the kind of thing you get in Jane Eyre, that kind of Mills and Boone.
并修复我的希望。天哪，这很现代，不是吗？我的意思是，在那里他能看出她想修复他，改造他，而他知道这不会奏效。再说一次，这就是你在《简·爱》中看到的那种东西，那种米尔斯和布恩式的。
I mean, it kind of establishes the template. So the marriage is fixed for early 1815. So Byron and Hobhouse set off from London on Christmas Eve, 1814. Byron spends Christmas at Six Mile Bottom with his sister. And then they set off again. And Hobhouse says of this journey, never was a lover in less haste. Oh dear.
我的意思是，它建立了一个模板。所以婚礼定在1815年初。所以拜伦和霍布豪斯在1814年平安夜从伦敦出发。拜伦在六英里底和他的妹妹一起度过了圣诞节。然后他们又出发了。霍布豪斯对这次旅行说，从来没有一个情人如此不急。哦，亲爱的。
They arrive very late on the 30th of December. Hobhouse inspects Annabella. Yeah. Records in his journal that evening, rather dowdy looking and wears a long and high dress, though she has excellent feet and ankles. Yeah, don't disregard feet and ankles, Tom. You can't. But over the next few days, he comes to admire her, thinks that she's a very
他们在12月30日很晚才到达。霍布豪斯视察了安娜贝拉。是的。那天晚上在日记中记录，看起来相当土气，穿着一件又长又高的裙子，尽管她有很好的脚和脚踝。是的，别忽视脚和脚踝，汤姆。你不能。但在接下来的几天里，他开始钦佩她，认为她是一个非常
impressive woman, describes her as very sensible. And his judgment is actually that Byron and Annabella are in love. He finds their relationship quite affecting. And the marriage takes place by special dispensation that's been issued by the Archbishop of Canterbury in the living room of Seaham House overlooking the North Sea. And this happens on New Year's Day, 1st of January, 1815. And the moment the wedding is done, Annabella bursts into tears. I mean, maybe that's kind of high emotion. I mean, who knows? And then after the wedding, anyone who's listened to our episode with Dan Jackson on the North-South divide will recognise this as a very, very Dan moment.
令人印象深刻的女人，形容她非常明智。他的判断实际上是拜伦和安娜贝拉相爱了。他发现他们的关系相当感人。婚礼是在坎特伯雷大主教颁发的特别许可下，在俯瞰北海的西汉姆大厦的客厅里举行的。这发生在1815年1月1日元旦。婚礼一结束，安娜贝拉就泪流满面。我的意思是，也许那是某种强烈的情绪。我的意思是，谁知道呢？婚礼结束后，任何听过我们与丹·杰克逊关于南北分歧的节目的人都会认出这是一个非常、非常“丹”的时刻。
Before they leave, before Byron and Annabella leave the house, some coal miners, ten of them, arrive fantastically dressed and they do a sword dance. Oh, that's nice. Which is the kind of custom that seems to have gone into abeyance since then. Yeah, that doesn't happen in the North of England. I associate that with more of Albania, frankly, with Byron's old stamping ground. Yeah, so that's great. I mean, it's, you know, wonderfully Northumbrian.
在他们离开之前，在拜伦和安娜贝拉离开房子之前，一些煤矿工人，十个，打扮得非常漂亮地到达了，他们跳了剑舞。哦，那很好。这似乎是自那时以来已经废弃的一种习俗。是的，这在英格兰北部不会发生。坦率地说，我把它与阿尔巴尼亚联系得更多，与拜伦的老根据地联系在一起。是的，所以那很好。我的意思是，你知道，非常诺森伯兰郡。
Yeah. And then they set off, the happy couple set off to another millbank property, which is Halnaby Hall near Darlington. So how does the honeymoon go? Oh, Tom, I'm dreading this. So Byron writes to Lady Melbourne and says, well, great, fabulous. dreading this. So, Byron writes to Lady Melbourne and says, it's all great, fabulous.
是的。然后他们出发了，这对幸福的夫妇出发前往另一处米尔班克房产，即达灵顿附近的哈尔纳比庄园。那么蜜月过得怎么样？哦，汤姆，我真害怕这个。所以拜伦写信给墨尔本夫人说，嗯，太棒了，美妙。害怕这个。所以，拜伦写信给墨尔本夫人说，一切都很好，美妙。
However, there are other accounts. Lady Byron's own account. So Lady Byron is Annabella. So Annabella is now Lady Byron. And also comments that Byron makes to his friends, and also things that he wrote in his memoirs, which subsequently get burnt by Hobhouse to spare scandal, but which various people had read and they remember it. So if you collate these reports, this is the account of the honeymoon. So they're driving through Durham. The bells are ringing for them in their honour.
然而，还有其他的说法。拜伦夫人自己的说法。所以拜伦夫人就是安娜贝拉。所以安娜贝拉现在是拜伦夫人。还有拜伦对他朋友发表的评论，以及他在回忆录中写的东西，这些后来被霍布豪斯烧毁以避免丑闻，但各种各样的人都读过，他们记得。所以如果你整理这些报告，这就是蜜月的描述。所以他们正开车穿过达勒姆。钟声为他们而响，以示对他们的敬意。
And Byron begins singing and basically ranting. And he tells Annabella she has doomed him. She'd rejected him two years earlier. If only she'd done that, she would have spared him damnation, alluding to the incest, but not actually naming it, but dropping very, very heavy hints. He says that she has doomed him to tragedy. He then starts slagging off her mother. Oh God. Says that Lady Melbourne says that her mother's a terrible woman. So it's not a happy drive. This is a very poor way to leave the service and the reception. Yeah. They arrive at Houndby Hall. Byron then apparently had written, I had Lady Byron on the sofa before dinner. He'd written this in his memoirs. But that's something, I suppose. I mean, that's a plus point.
拜伦开始唱歌，基本上是在咆哮。他告诉安娜贝拉她注定了他。她在两年前拒绝了他。如果她早点那样做，她就会让他免于诅咒，暗示了乱伦，但没有真正点名，而是给出了非常、非常强烈的暗示。他说她注定了他要走向悲剧。然后他开始抨击她的母亲。哦，上帝。说墨尔本夫人说她母亲是个可怕的女人。所以这不是一次愉快的驾驶。这是离开仪式和招待会的一种非常糟糕的方式。是的。他们到达了亨德比庄园。拜伦然后显然写道，我在晚餐前让拜伦夫人在沙发上。他在回忆录中写了这一点。但这算什么，我想。我的意思是，那是一个加分项。
It's then time for them to go to bed. Byron informs Lady Byron, I hate sleeping with women. I don't want to go to sleep with a woman, but if you've got to, well, OK, fair enough. So that's not particularly appealing. And by that, he means literally sleeping. Literally sleeping in the bed. And they go to sleep. And then Byron wakes up in the middle of the night. The curtains are a bright scarlet.
然后是他们上床睡觉的时间。拜伦通知拜伦夫人，我讨厌和女人睡觉。我不想和女人睡觉，但如果你必须，嗯，好吧，公平地说。所以这并不是特别吸引人。他的意思是字面上的睡觉。字面上的在床上睡觉。他们睡着了。然后拜伦在半夜醒来。窗帘是鲜红色的。
There's a flickering candle. And Byron cries out, good God, I am surely in hell. So poor Lady Byron. So poor, you know, poor Lady Byron. I mean, just awful, awful. I mean,
有一支闪烁的蜡烛。拜伦大喊，上帝啊，我肯定在地狱里。所以可怜的拜伦夫人。所以可怜的，你知道，可怜的拜伦夫人。我的意思是，太可怕了，太可怕了。我的意思是，
this is what he does. He's Byron. He plays up the melodrama. You know, he does all this kind of stuff. This is what happens if you spend too much time on your maths.
这就是他所做的。他是拜伦。他夸大了情节剧。你知道，他做了所有这些事情。如果你在数学上花太多时间，就会发生这种情况。
Right. Because she doesn't recognise that there is an element of self-parody to this. Right. And so Augusta would have recognised this, would have laughed him out of it, would have
对。因为她没有意识到这其中有一种自我模仿的成分。对。所以奥古斯塔会认出这一点，会嘲笑他，会
made a joke of it. And Annabella doesn't. And so this just reminds Byron more and more of Augusta. And so he starts writing to Augusta and dropping hints about how close he is to Augusta. And that just makes Lady Byron more and more kind of rigid with nervousness and tension. And so it's terrible. Now, the thing is that there are clearly moments where they behave like a conventional loving couple. He's writing these poems, they're called Hebrew
拿它开玩笑。而安娜贝拉没有。所以这只会让拜伦更多地想起奥古斯塔。于是他开始给奥古斯塔写信，暗示他和奥古斯塔有多亲密。这只会让拜伦夫人变得越来越僵硬，充满紧张和不安。所以这太可怕了。现在，问题在于显然有他们表现得像一对传统恩爱夫妻的时刻。他正在写这些诗，它们被称为希伯来
melodies. He's been asked by a Jewish composer to write some poetry based on the Old Testament that this Jewish composer, Isaac Nathan, can set to music. And Lady Byron is kind of copying it up. And these are some of Byron's most beautiful poetry. So people may have heard the destruction of Seneca Rib. The Assyrian came down like a wolf on the fold and his cohorts were gleaming in purple and gold. So it's all great stuff. And Lady Byron is helping him with that. But then the time comes for them to head south. And where did they head?
旋律。一位犹太作曲家要求他根据旧约写一些诗歌，这位犹太作曲家艾萨克·内森可以为之谱曲。而拜伦夫人正在抄写它。这些是拜伦最美丽的诗歌。所以人们可能听说过《西拿基立的毁灭》。亚述人像狼一样冲进羊圈，他们的队伍在紫色和金色中闪闪发光。所以这都是很棒的东西。拜伦夫人正在帮他做这件事。但随后他们向南出发的时间到了。他们去了哪里？
Oh, not to his sister's house. Six mile bottom. That is exactly where they go. And by this point annabella is really starting to put you know she's a mathematician she's trying to do together and she's arriving at four and when they meet with augusta all her suspicions are confirmed because by now byron is behaving with i think palpable cruelty basically saying to annabella you know you go to bed i don't need you anymore
哦，不是去他妹妹的房子。六英里底。那正是他们去的地方。到这个时候，安娜贝拉真的开始把，你知道，她是数学家，她试图把事情放在一起，她在四点到达，当他们见到奥古斯塔时，她所有的怀疑都得到了证实，因为现在拜伦的行为，我认为有明显的残忍，基本上对安娜贝拉说，你知道，你去睡觉吧，我不再需要你了，
i've got my sister i mean horrible behavior yeah and in due course he basically involves them in a threesome yes golly his delight was to work us both well so that's annabella writing after the failure of the marriage oh and he basically he you know he's lying on the sofa and he's making them both lie beside him would you like to have an incestuous threesome with me and my sister? I mean, that's not a request you often get, is it? I mean, that's bad enough. You know, the man you've just married is having an adulterous affair with his sister. And wants you to get involved.
我有我的妹妹，我的意思是可怕的行为，是的，在适当的时候，他基本上让他们参与了三人行，是的，天哪，他的乐趣是让我们两个都工作，嗯，那是安娜贝拉在婚姻失败后写的，哦，他基本上，他（你知道，他躺在沙发上，他让他们俩都躺在他身边，你想和我还有我妹妹来一场乱伦的三人行吗？我的意思是，那不是你经常收到的请求，不是吗？我的意思是，那已经够糟糕了。你知道，你刚娶的男人正在和他的妹妹发生通奸关系。并且想让你参与进来。
When she writes about this, there's something so tragic because what really upsets her, she writes, I was sensible that he was more warm towards Augusta than he was to me. And when Lord and Lady Byron move on to London, Augusta goes with them. I mean, in many ways, he can behave terribly, but he has deep reserves of generosity, of kindness as well. Why is he being so cruel? I think he's angry with Augusta. I think he's angry with himself. I think he's angry with Annabella for the reasons that he said that, you know, if only she'd married him earlier, that none of this would have happened. He does have massive financial anxieties because he, predictably, he's taken a house that they can't really afford on Piccadilly Terrace,
当她写到这一点时，有一些如此悲剧的事情，因为真正让她心烦意乱的是，她写道，我感觉到他对奥古斯塔比对我更热情。当拜伦勋爵和夫人搬到伦敦时，奥古斯塔和他们一起去了。我的意思是，在很多方面，他可以表现得非常糟糕，但他也有慷慨和善良的深层储备。他为什么要这么残忍？我想他生奥古斯塔的气。我想他生自己的气。我想他生安娜贝拉的气，原因正如他所说，你知道，如果她早点嫁给他，这一切都不会发生。他确实有巨大的经济焦虑，因为，不出所料，他在皮卡迪利露台租了一栋他们负担不起的房子，
which is, people who know London, it's right by Hyde Park, overlooking Green Park. And I think also he feels trapped. And whenever Byron feels trapped, he behaves very badly. Lashes out. Yeah, he kind of lashes out. And there's a social occasion that sums up why he would have been under stress. I mean, it must be one of the worst parties of all time. So they have this kind of soiree at Piccadilly Terrace. Lady Melbourne comes with Lady Caroline Lamb.
也就是，了解伦敦的人知道，它就在海德公园旁边，俯瞰绿园。而且我也认为他感到被困住了。每当拜伦感到被困住时，他的行为就非常糟糕。猛烈抨击。是的，他有点猛烈抨击。有一个社交场合总结了他为什么会承受压力。我的意思是，这一定是史上最糟糕的派对之一。所以他们在皮卡迪利露台举行了这种晚会。墨尔本夫人带着卡罗琳·兰姆夫人来了。
Annabella is there. And Augusta is there. Oh my God, all his women in one room. And Annabella's mother. That is so weird. Oh my word. Why would you put yourself through that? I mean- I know.
安娜贝拉在那里。奥古斯塔也在那里。哦，我的上帝，他所有的女人都在一个房间里。还有安娜贝拉的母亲。这太奇怪了。哦，我的天。你为什么要让自己经历那种事？我的意思是——我知道。
Why would you not just claim you're ill or disappear? I think Byron is ill. I mean, I think he's psychologically ill. And this is the last time that Caroline will see Byron. Because shortly after this, Napoleon all this time, you know, great adventures, he's been sent to Elba, he's come back. And the Battle of Waterloo will be fought a few weeks after this. And Caroline's brother gets wounded at the battle.
你为什么不干脆说你病了或者消失？我认为拜伦病了。我的意思是，我认为他在心理上病了。这是卡罗琳最后一次见到拜伦。因为在这之后不久，拿破仑一直以来，你知道，伟大的冒险，他被送到了厄尔巴岛，他又回来了。滑铁卢战役将在几周后打响。卡罗琳的兄弟在战斗中受伤了。
And so she leaves London to go to Brussels. And while she is in Brussels and then in Paris, all hell breaks loose and she will never see Byron again, because again, spoiler, Byron is going to end up going into exile. The crisis comes to a head in November 1815. And by now, Annabella is eight months pregnant and Byron's stress is kind of reaching breaking point. He's drinking very, very heavily. Just to kind of add horror to the mix. He's having an affair with an actress, dropping hints about that, both to Augusta and to Annabella. And then on the 8th of November, bailiffs force their way into the house. And Byron confesses to Hobhouse that, you know, I feel half mad. He feels half mad with the pressure of his marriage,
所以她离开伦敦去了布鲁塞尔。当她在布鲁塞尔然后去巴黎时，地狱之门大开，她将再也见不到拜伦了，因为再次剧透，拜伦最终将流亡。危机在1815年11月达到顶峰。到目前为止，安娜贝拉已经怀孕八个月了，拜伦的压力已经到了崩溃的边缘。他喝得非常、非常厉害。只是为了增加恐怖感。他和一个女演员有染，暗示了这一点，既对奥古斯塔也对安娜贝拉。然后在11月8日，法警强行进入房子。拜伦向霍布豪斯承认，你知道，我觉得自己半疯了。他感到婚姻的压力让他半疯了，
with the pressure of the, you know, the financial humiliation that he's suffering. He says, my financial worries are doubled by the fact that I have a wife. But he remains a kind of proud aristocrat. Murray offers to lend him money. He owes £1,500 and the library has been offered up austerity. And Murray says, I'll pay off the debt so you can keep the library. And Byron refuses. He refuses to take money for his royalties. And the person who helps him out is Sir Ralph, Lady Byron's father. And the bailiffs move out on the 9th of December, just as Lady Byron is going into labour. And on the 10th of December, she gives birth to a daughter who is called Augusta.
随着，你知道，他正在遭受的经济羞辱的压力。他说，我的经济担忧因为我有一个妻子而加倍了。但他仍然是一个骄傲的贵族。默里提出借钱给他。他欠了1500英镑，图书馆已经被拿出来抵债了。默里说，我会还清债务，这样你就可以保留图书馆。而拜伦拒绝了。他拒绝为他的版税拿钱。而帮助他的人是拉尔夫爵士，拜伦夫人的父亲。法警在12月9日搬走了，就在拜伦夫人即将分娩时。12月10日，她生下了一个女儿，名叫奥古斯塔。
Oh, come on, Byron. Tom, he's just behaving very self-indulgently now. I'm sorry. He is. But her second name is Ada. And so unsurprisingly, by her mother, she will come to be known as Ada. The birth of the child does not, it is fair to say, bring them closer together. And Byron's response to the fact that his wife is recovering from labour is to start dropping hints, not about incest, which Lady Byron now knows all about, but about sodomy. Although he does try to assure her that, as he says, I have never done an act that would bring me under the law, at least on this side of the water. So basically saying I haven't had any gay affairs, at least since I came back from my travels. But he's not on this side
哦，拜伦，算了吧。汤姆，他现在表现得太放纵了。我很抱歉。他是。但她的第二个名字是艾达。所以不出所料，她的母亲会称她为艾达。孩子的出生，公平地说，并没有让他们更亲近。拜伦对他的妻子正在从分娩中恢复的反应是开始暗示，不是关于乱伦，拜伦夫人现在对此一清二楚，而是关于鸡奸。尽管他确实试图向她保证，正如他所说，我从未做过任何会让我触犯法律的行为，至少在这片水域的这一边。所以基本上是说我没有过任何同性恋关系，至少在我从旅行回来之后。但他不在这边
of the water. So he's deliberately leaving the implication open, which is what he does, right? There must be a cruelty in his nature, Tom. Yeah, I think so. It's his image. I mean, that's the image of the Byronic hero, the nameless crime. It's what he's all about. Yeah, but to keep taunting her and leaving the hits. Yeah, I agree. It's unspeakably cruel behaviour. And Lady Byron, by this point, is at breaking point. And so she says, I want to take Ada, newborn girl, to go and see my parents. And Byron's response to this is, yes, please go and go as soon as possible. So Lady Byron by now basically is convinced that he's mad. And so
的水域。所以他故意留下暗示，这就是他所做的，对吧？他的本性中一定有一种残忍，汤姆。是的，我想是的。这是他的形象。我的意思是，那是拜伦式英雄的形象，无名的罪行。这就是他的全部。是的，但不断嘲弄她并留下暗示。是的，我同意。这是无法形容的残忍行为。而拜伦夫人，到这个时候，已经到了崩溃的边缘。所以她说，我想带艾达，刚出生的女孩，去见我的父母。而拜伦对此的反应是，是的，请去，尽快去。所以拜伦夫人现在基本上确信他疯了。所以
she, as Caroline had earlier done, she starts rummaging through his drawers and his trunks and everything in his letter cases, searching for evidence that she will be able to produce to demand a separation. And she discovers in a travelling trunk, a bottle of laudanum, so opium, and a secret copy of Justine by the Marquis de Sade. So this is what Byron has been reading. And on the 14th of January, before she leaves him, she goes to a doctor and consults with him about Byron. And I'll read it in full because her testimony is really interesting. She says this about Byron. He is convinced that he must be wicked, is foredoomed to evil and compelled by some irresistible power to follow his destiny, doing violence all the time to his feelings. Under the influence of this imagined fatalism,
她，正如卡罗琳早些时候所做的那样，她开始翻箱倒柜，翻找他的抽屉和行李箱以及他信件盒里的所有东西，寻找她能够用来要求分居的证据。她在旅行箱里发现了一瓶鸦片酊，也就是鸦片，还有萨德侯爵的《朱斯蒂娜》的秘密副本。所以这就是拜伦一直在读的东西。1月14日，在她离开他之前，她去看了一位医生，并就拜伦咨询了他。我会全文朗读，因为她的证词真的很有趣。她这样评价拜伦。他确信自己一定是邪恶的，注定要作恶，并被迫被某种不可抗拒的力量追随他的命运，一直对他自己的感情施加暴力。在这种想象中的宿命论的影响下，
he will be most unkind to those whom he loves best. I think that's absolutely true. Suffering agonies at the same time for the pain he gives them. He then believes the world to be governed by a malignant spirit and at one time conceived himself to be a fallen angel, though he was half ashamed of the idea and grew cunning and mysterious about it after I seemed to detect it. Tom, do you think he's mentally ill? I think he's under such stress as effectively to be so at this point, yes. And so that evening, after she's been to consult with the doctor, she is sitting with Byron and with Augusta. And Byron says, when shall we three meet again? And Lady Byron replies to him, in heaven, I hope.
他会对那些他最爱的人非常不友善。我认为那是绝对真实的。同时为他给他们带来的痛苦而遭受折磨。然后他相信世界是由一种恶毒的精神统治的，一度认为自己是一个堕落的天使，尽管他对自己有这个想法感到半羞愧，并在我似乎察觉到它之后变得狡猾和神秘。汤姆，你认为他精神病吗？我认为他承受着如此大的压力，以至于在这一点上实际上是这样，是的。所以那天晚上，在她咨询医生之后，她正和拜伦以及奥古斯塔坐在一起。拜伦说，我们三个什么时候再见面？拜伦夫人回答他，在天堂，我希望。
And early the next morning before Byron's got up, she leaves. She takes Ada with her. And on the 2nd of February, Byron gets a letter from Sir Ralph Milbank, Lady Byron's father, asking him to agree to a separation. And Ada, just a big spoiler, she is, of course, Ada Lovelace, isn't she? The sort of computing pioneer. So she got her maths from her mum. She does, yeah.
第二天一大早，在拜伦起床之前，她离开了。她带着艾达走了。2月2日，拜伦收到了拉尔夫·米尔班克爵士，也就是拜伦夫人的父亲的信，要求他同意分居。而艾达，只是一个大剧透，她当然是艾达·洛夫莱斯，不是吗？那种计算先驱。所以她从她妈妈那里得到了数学天赋。她确实，是的。
And she gets her very self-destructive streak from Byron. But we'll perhaps come to that at the end of the next episode. Now, what is interesting is that this letter from Sir Ralph Milbank comes as a complete shock to Byron. And he writes back to Sir Ralph denying any suggestion of ill treatment. And it is fair to say that all the accounts of Byron's ill treatment do come from Annabella. I mean, clearly she has been driven to leave him. I mean, she's a very pious, devout woman, clearly still in love with him. So she's not leaving him for no reason. But I think it is fair to just to kind of raise the possibility that she might be perhaps overshadowing things. So I think a kind of classic example of the scope that exists for misunderstanding between Byron and Lady Byron. he then comes back and he spends the night downstairs throwing bottles at the room in which she is giving birth, presumably to kind of disturb her and upset her when she's giving birth. And she
她从拜伦那里得到了她非常自我毁灭的倾向。但我们也许会在下一集的结尾谈到这一点。现在，有趣的是，这封来自拉尔夫·米尔班克爵士的信对拜伦来说是一个完全的打击。他回信给拉尔夫，否认任何虐待的暗示。公平地说，所有关于拜伦虐待的说法都来自安娜贝拉。我的意思是，显然她是被逼离开他的。我的意思是，她是一个非常虔诚、笃信的女人，显然仍然爱着他。所以她不是无缘无故离开他的。但我认为公平地提出一种可能性，即她可能也许夸大了事情。所以我认为这是一个经典的例子，说明拜伦和拜伦夫人之间存在误解的空间。他然后回来，他在楼下过夜，向她正在分娩的房间扔瓶子，大概是为了在分娩时打扰她和让她心烦。而她
tells this to Hobhouse and Hobhouse thinks, I can't be true. And so he goes and looks at the ceiling where Byron is supposed to have thrown the bottles. And there's no marks of any bottles having been thrown there. And Hobhouse's conclusion is that this is Byron's supposed to have thrown the bottles. And there's no marks of any bottles having been thrown there. And Hobhouse's conclusion is that this is Byron's playful habit of knocking off the heads of the bottles with a poker and that this sufficiently accounted for the noise. I mean, you might say, well, you know, I mean, even, you know, if your wife is in labour, knocking bottles off with a poker is a bit unsettling, but I don't think there was deliberate cruelty there. So it's difficult to know. And this is why Hobhouse much later says that byron could have ridden out the scandal if he'd
告诉了霍布豪斯，霍布豪斯认为，这不可能是真的。所以他去看了拜伦被认为扔瓶子的天花板。那里没有任何扔过瓶子的痕迹。而霍布豪斯的结论是，这是拜伦的，被认为扔了瓶子。那里没有任何扔过瓶子的痕迹。而霍布豪斯的结论是，这是拜伦的，用拨火棍敲掉瓶盖的顽皮习惯，这足以解释噪音。我的意思是，你可能会说，嗯，你知道，我的意思是，即使，你知道，如果你的妻子正在分娩，用拨火棍敲掉瓶子也有点令人不安，但我认为那里没有蓄意的残忍。所以很难知道。这就是为什么霍布豪斯很久以后说，如果拜伦愿意，他本可以度过这场丑闻，
wanted you know he says there was not the slightest necessity even in appearance for his going abroad but tom first of all hobhouse's party pre he's byron's old friend and secondly the portrait you have given of their marriage and their relationship given what you've already told us about Byron, about his patterns of behavior, the traumas he suffered as a little boy, all of these kinds of things. It does sound plausible. I mean, it does sound like he would have done all these things. It does. It does. I think it shows him at his absolute worst. And I think there was no possibility of his writing out the scandal, not least because by this point, Lady Caroline Lamb is back from Paris and the news has got out that Lady Byron has left her husband. And Caroline rallies to her cousin-in-law's support and she starts spreading two terrible rumours. And they
他当时说，他出国甚至在表面上都没有丝毫必要。但汤姆，首先，霍布豪斯的派对，他是拜伦的老朋友，其次，你给出的关于他们的婚姻和关系的画像，考虑到你已经告诉我们关于拜伦的事情，关于他的行为模式，他小时候遭受的创伤，所有这些事情。这听起来确实可信。我的意思是，这听起来确实像他会做所有这些事情。确实。确实。我认为这展示了他最糟糕的一面。而且我认为他没有可能度过这场丑闻，不仅因为到这个时候，卡罗琳·兰姆夫人已经从巴黎回来了，而且有消息传出拜伦夫人已经离开了她的丈夫。卡罗琳支持她的表亲，她开始散布两个可怕的谣言。它们
are that Byron has been having an incestuous affair with his sister and that he is an enthusiastic practitioner of sodomy and she tells Annabella who of course is desperate to keep Ada because there's no guarantee that the mother will keep the child in the case of separation she says I am giving you this information so that you can menace him with the knowledge of it and it will surely make him tremble. And there is a particularly damning charge, which is heard by Lord Holland, who then tells Hobhouse that Byron had tried to sodomize Lady Byron. And Byron says this isn't true, writes to the lawyers and gets Lady Byron to acknowledge that this charge of sodomy, that it did not form any part of the charges which, in the event of a separation by agreement not taking place, she should have been compelled to make against Lord Byron. But that's ambivalent.
是拜伦一直与他的妹妹进行乱伦关系，并且他是一个热情的鸡奸实践者，她告诉安娜贝拉，安娜贝拉当然渴望保留艾达，因为在分居的情况下，母亲不能保证保留孩子，她说我给你这个信息是为了你可以用它来威胁他，它肯定会让他颤抖。有一个特别严重的指控，被霍兰勋爵听到，然后告诉霍布豪斯，拜伦曾试图鸡奸拜伦夫人。而拜伦说这不是真的，写信给律师，让拜伦夫人承认这个鸡奸指控，它并不构成她在协议分居不发生的情况下，被迫对拜伦勋爵提出的指控的一部分。但这很矛盾。
So is it a denial that it happened, or is she saying that she wouldn't use it in court? I mean, it's not clear. Yeah. It'd be terribly humiliating for her to have used it in court, wouldn't it? I mean, it's unlikely she would have used it in court. It would. And I think it's almost become the orthodoxy that this did happen and that this was her breaking point. And there's William Gibson and Bruce Sterling wrote a book, The Difference Engine, in which Ada Lovelace and Babbage have got together and the computer age has begun in Victorian
所以这是一个否认它发生过的声明，还是她在说她不会在法庭上使用它？我的意思是，这不清楚。是的。她在法庭上使用它会让她非常丢脸，不是吗？我的意思是，她不太可能在法庭上使用它。会的。而且我认为这几乎已经成为正统观念，即这确实发生了，这就是她的崩溃点。威廉·吉布森和布鲁斯·斯特林写了一本书，《差分机》，其中艾达·洛夫莱斯和巴贝奇走到了一起，计算机时代在维多利亚时代的
Britain. So it's a counterfactual. And the pivot point in that history is that Lady Byron, rather than leaving her husband, submits to it and stays with Byron and helps Byron to become prime minister. An unlikely prospect, I think. An unlikely prospect, yes. Anyway, so the scandal is now spreading across London,
英国开始了。所以这是一个反事实。而那段历史的枢纽点是，拜伦夫人没有离开她的丈夫，而是屈服了，留在了拜伦身边，并帮助拜伦成为了首相。我认为这是一个不太可能的前景。不太可能的前景，是的。总之，丑闻现在正在伦敦蔓延，
across Britain, across Europe. At the 8th of April, Byron goes to a ball. He is cut. He is advised by his friends, do not go to Parliament. You will be hissed. Do not step outside your front door. People are kind of massing. They want to do you violence.
在英国，在欧洲。4月8日，拜伦去参加了一个舞会。他被冷落了。他的朋友建议他，不要去议会。你会受到嘘声。不要走出你的前门。人们正在聚集。他们想对你施加暴力。
The rumours of his homosexuality are provoking the kind of mob violence that Byron had always been in dread of. And so he feels he has no choice but to sign the deed of separation that's been drawn up for him by his wife's lawyers, which he does on the 21st of April. And the next day he leaves London. He is going in a coach that in typically Byronic fashion has been modelled on that used by Napoleon to take him to Waterloo. He heads to Dover on the 25th of April. He takes ship for Ostend. Hobhouse has gone with him. He's on the harbour front at Dover and watches him
关于他同性恋的谣言正在激起拜伦一直恐惧的那种暴民暴力。所以他觉得他别无选择，只能签署由他妻子的律师为他起草的分居契约，他在4月21日这样做了。第二天他离开了伦敦。他坐在一辆典型的拜伦式马车里，这辆马车是仿照拿破仑带他去滑铁卢时使用的马车制造的。他在4月25日前往多佛。他乘船前往奥斯坦德。霍布豪斯和他一起去了。他在多佛的港口前，看着他
until he can see his friend no more. And that evening Hobhouse writes, God bless him for a gallant spirit and a kind one. That's an ironic thing to say, given that he's behaved. I mean, whatever you think of his behaviour, he has not treated Annabella kindly. No, I don't think he's been kind at all. And I think another more astute commentary on the whole affair is made by another friend of Byron's, a great admirer of his, Sir Walter Scott, the novelist and poet, who writes of Byron that he had child-heralded himself and outlawed himself into two greater resemblance with the pictures of his imagination. I think that basically what Scott is saying there is that Byron is the primal example of how celebrity can feed on itself. Tom, I know we've gone on too long, and Theo will be cross with us, and it would be cross with me for asking you your last question, but just on that issue, is that true? The self-destructiveness in Byron, the anxieties or the hangups or whatever
直到他再也看不见他的朋友。那天晚上，霍布豪斯写道：愿上帝保佑他，因为他有着勇敢而善良的精神。考虑到他的所作所为，这真是一个讽刺的说法。我的意思是，无论你怎么看待他的行为，他对待安娜贝拉并不友善。不，我认为他一点也不友善。我认为拜伦的另一位朋友，也是他的崇拜者，小说家兼诗人沃尔特·司各特爵士，对整件事的评论更为敏锐。他写道，拜伦将自己妖魔化、放逐化，使自己越来越像他想象中的那些形象。我认为司各特基本上是在说，拜伦是名人效应如何自我蚕食的典型例子。汤姆，我知道我们聊得太久了，西奥会生我们的气，他也会因为我问你最后一个问题而生我的气，但就这个问题而言，这是真的吗？拜伦身上的自我毁灭倾向，那些焦虑、心结或其他什么东西，
about sexuality and stuff, they were there from the very beginning, his very abusive upbringing and all that sort of stuff. How much would they have happened anyway? Or how much is he consciously, because there's so many times in this story that you've told where he's almost consciously playing a part, isn't there, of the Byronic hero. Do you think that that's actually what undid him? That he was seduced by his own myth? Or do you think the demons within him would always have led him to this sort of dark place? I think that if he had not been as famous as he was, none of this would have become the scandal that it did. He is given license to behave as he does by his fame. And as events will show, although he is driven into exile by what Macaulay famously describes as one of the periodic fits of morality. Macaulay famously says, we know of no spectacle more ridiculous than the British public enjoying one of its periodic fits
关于性取向之类的问题，从一开始就存在了，他那充满虐待的成长环境等等。这些问题在多大程度上是必然会发生的？或者他在多大程度上是有意识的——因为在你讲述的故事中，有很多次他几乎是有意识地在扮演拜伦式英雄的角色，不是吗？你认为这真的是毁掉他的原因吗？他被自己的神话所诱惑了吗？还是你认为他内心的恶魔总是会把他引向这种黑暗的境地？我认为，如果他没有那么出名，这一切都不会演变成那样的丑闻。他的名声给了他肆意妄为的许可。正如后续事件所表明的那样，尽管他被麦考利所描述的“周期性道德发作”之一驱逐出境。麦考利曾有名言：我们不知道还有什么比英国公众享受其周期性道德发作更荒谬的景象了。
of morality. Byron will be able to reconfigure this entire episode into further material for his myth and to burnish his poetry in a way that we will explore in episode four. Because although Byron is socially ruined in England, his reputation and fame as a poet is only amplified by it. And the sense of him as a mythic figure, the paradigmatic figure of post-Napoleonic Europe, is completely shaped by the fact that he is driven from England in moral disgrace. Okay. So next time, if you're a member of the Rest is History Club, you can listen to that final episode right now. We'll be talking about vampirism. We're talking about Byron in Italy with the Shelleys with Percy Buscelli and of course
拜伦将能够把整个事件重新构建为他神话的进一步素材，并以一种我们将在第四集中探讨的方式来润色他的诗歌。因为尽管拜伦在英国社会名声扫地，但他作为诗人的声誉和名望却因此得到了提升。他作为后拿破仑时代欧洲典范人物的神话形象，完全是由他因道德耻辱被逐出英国这一事实所塑造的。好的。那么下一次，如果你是“历史余韵”俱乐部的成员，你现在就可以收听最后一集了。我们将讨论吸血鬼主义。我们将讨论拜伦在意大利与雪莱夫妇、珀西·比希·雪莱，当然还有
Mary Shelley the author of Frankenstein Byron will return to Greece for the Greek War of Independence and it's there of course Tom
《弗兰肯斯坦》的作者玛丽·雪莱在一起。拜伦将回到希腊参加希腊独立战争，当然，汤姆，就是在那里，
that he meets his destiny so that episode will be out on Thursday or right now if you're a member of the Restless History Club and until then
他遇见了自己的命运。所以那一集将在周四播出，如果你是“历史余韵”俱乐部的成员，现在就可以收听了。在那之前，
goodbye bye bye And until then, goodbye. Bye-bye. we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见，再见。在那之前，再见。再见。我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告内容、额外剧集并优先获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。